[Music]
there are a few people in the world who
just seemed to shine bright they are a
light bulb in a dark room and Carolyn
Adams is one of those people she's a
world-renowned dancer a pioneer and a
teacher and she just seems to have this
magical perspective on the world and how
to approach it with such intense purpose
I had the chance to sit down and talk to
her and I left completely inspired this
is a bit of optimism Carolyn thanks so
much for joining me what was it like for
you as you were trying to build a career
in the arts trying to be a dancer as a
young black woman during the civil
rights era during the 1950s and 60s well
it was a pretty smooth ride I actually
didn't faced too many obstacles in my
early years or even later and it's
partly because I knew what I wanted to
do I didn't have low expectations but it
sort of had none I just knew I wanted to
dance and then I was very fortunate I
mean to an elementary school that had
dance and I went to a high school that
had danced and then I started training
there really weren't a lot of barriers
for African Americans in terms of
training now early on little bit before
me some of the classes were segregated
and we tell this story about how the
kind teachers would let the Negro
students take class in the hallway
couldn't go in the studio I do tell my
students that because I want them to
know how different the world was even in
my lifetime but by the time I came along
you had two major institutions that were
quite multiracial multicultural one of
them was katherine dunham school and
company and the other one was the new
dance group and they were international
interracial dance collectives and that
came as early as the 20s where all of my
consciousness around disk kicked
was when I became a teenager and we were
starting to do work in the civil rights
movement hearing up for that
and my parents were involved in politics
and journalism my mother wrote a full
account of the Emmett Till murder
because Emmett Till and my sister and I
were about the same age and this
horrible thing happened and so my mother
was really very moved by it that's
really when we started to get involved
it was really more from an activist
point of view what we were not really
subjected to a lot of discrimination and
I think what's really interesting about
it is that my father was born in 1901 my
mom was born in 1912 the year the
Titanic went down and so you can imagine
he was in Georgia and she was in
Minnesota and they met in New York but
they had very very different experiences
and certainly suffered a lot of the
especially my father being in the South
suffered a lot of discriminators and
they just lived with that but they
really didn't have him of the victim
mentality even though they had been
subjected to discrimination and they
certainly saw horrible things they
weren't oblivious but they were
proactive and prepared how did their
experience come out as parents because
clearly they had an experience that they
didn't want their children to have right
and so how did they prepare you for what
could happen well I think it's because
they were so prepared my mother was a
very accomplished musician and composer
and my father was a journalist and so I
think they had found themselves in some
way and I also think what's so wonderful
is the way that they found each other
they were a team so we felt they're
secure I think it's so interesting that
intellectually you understand what's
going on in the world I mean as you said
your father's a journalist you were
involved as young activists you were
very intellectually aware of the state
of America at the time and yet you say
you didn't face much racism and had a
smooth ride but you had to be unaware of
for example that you were the first
african-american in the Paul Taylor
Dance Company well I was the second but
everyone says that on the first because
the first african-american was
fair-skinned
I guess people didn't know so out of
respect for her I like to say that but
people get embarrassed when I say that
what was her name Elizabeth so you had
to at least been aware that you were one
of the first I'm sorry to be so
resistant but the thing is that when I
joined the Taylor company there were six
people didn't feel like such a minority
situation yeah this is a small company
and we were just building the company so
I felt like a founder no way do you
think with the Arts ahead of the curve
well I think they're inherently more
diverse and more function oriented
there's more collaboration and we can't
do this thing alone especially in dance
I'm very curious what your thoughts are
about what's going on in the world right
now especially given your very different
experience growing up I had such a range
of emotions I started out with just a
lot of fear my own mortality and then
the way that overlap with all of this
racial traveling stuff really been sort
of an existential crisis and I think
that in terms of hearing all the
different voices about black lives
matter which of course they do I think
that that didn't really resonate with a
lot of people until they witnessed a
murder on TV but then a lot of black
people have said oh this has been going
on for years and years it does give you
an entry point for a different kind of
conversation typical conversations often
happen somewhat circumstantial you're
sort of hard to schedule one but I think
there have been more serious
conversations because you got to get a
little bit beneath the surface where
suddenly people think oh my goodness
that's what it just like to be a victim
what did you you know handcuffed and
then murdered while you're begging for
your mother that would be the initial
thing just you get it people's feelings
you get where people live I appreciate
this idea that something has to happen
before somebody has the wherewithal to
say I need to talk to about something
bigger than this
there's always something underlying
right
but it takes it takes a thing to force a
conversation yeah and then you hope that
you're open to it I think that becomes
the difficult part right and either side
can start the difficult conversation
well it's funny cuz don't you think
about it within the context of a
therapeutic situation therapy sessions
are often very difficult conversations
right but it's what is the comfort level
and what is the trust and what does the
interaction mean anyway I think those
kinds of environments can be created
have you had any difficult conversations
recently have you had to create that
space yeah I was talking to somebody
about race and about some person who had
said some races thing to some other
person than it was over her and it
became a little scandal and this white
person who was telling you this story
was talking about how furious he was
with this other white person who had
made this racial slur and I was trying
to say well she was probably brought up
that way and he said to me which was
real lesson to me he said well I was too
but I made a choice he said I grew up
hearing the n-word and everything of my
whole life
and he said she's responsible for making
a choice not to do that and that was
kind of a revelation for me what was the
revelation well just the idea that
somebody is responsible through not only
their behavior but their willingness to
look at things out of their own eyes and
not those have been sort of filled their
ears yeah the idea that we're active
participants in our own life right yeah
there's a poem by Philip Larkin of which
the first stands is they [ __ ] you up
your mum and dad they may not mean to
but they do they fill you with the
faults they had and add some extra just
for you and it is that we carry this
baggage and the question is will
probably gain more good baggage but what
bags do we leave behind as well right
and the fact that we're actively we
should be hopefully actively examining
the bags were holding at all times which
is this idea of self-examination
right I I guess that's also a bit of a
luxury because in a way if you've got
those patterns set
and there's nothing really to challenge
it it somehow means that you have to
break away so that you become poorest
before you can even start to make those
choices there has to be a mechanism that
takes us from tension to safety well I
think that's a very powerful idea it
also explains why it's so important
especially in art but in teaching in
education in general what you really
want to do is teach the person before
you can teach the subject people say
what do you teach I said I teach people
you want to build skills but you also
want to build self knowledge and the
porousness within the person so that
they have their receptors so you're
trying to do both things at once you're
trying to give them the skills of reason
and judgment and all that but you have
to make them the author of their own
thoughts or their authors their own
movements I love this this goes to a
deep sense of purpose right especially
for a teacher like yourself which is
you're not there to teach a curriculum
you're not there to teach a movement or
a choreography you're there to teach a
human being and every teacher formally
or informally is responsible for helping
the human beings in their care become
better versions of themselves and they
use their discipline or their subject as
a means to do it but the end of the day
is that this person child or adult leave
this conversation or leave this
classroom slightly better than they went
in not slightly better informed not just
slightly more intelligent not just
slightly better at the choreography but
actually having learned that capacity
for self examination or to have an
opinion on the path of life that they
can choose yeah and part of that is
getting them to recognize that they have
to be in the driver's seat if they have
to be in charge of that so you got to
get her to know what they don't know so
that they can then go after it actively
and not pass it when one of the ways to
really inhibit another person's life
without putting them behind bars is to
convince them that they have nothing to
offer this is the track
of discrimination you teleport person
they have nothing to give forth people
are always giving to other poor people
the notion of empowerment has to do with
one's ability to reach out and be abused
and of assistance we are human animals
we connect you isolate people and tell
them they have nothing to give you're
just you're on the course to destroying
them it's the most demoralizing
heartless thing you can do we spend so
much time telling individuals or even
populations that they have no value
which perpetuates the problem and what
we need to do here is is convince people
who may have not been convinced of that
in the past that they have great values
the thing that I was struck by that you
said before that I loved was that it
requires partnership that nobody can do
this themselves that in all these cases
that we're talking about there's at
least two there's a student there's a
teacher there's black and there's white
you know there's me and you well we're
communicators the interplay in the
interaction and the response this is our
oxygen which is why this pandemic has
been so difficult through mmm most
people if we have to define you dancer
pioneer teacher which is the word that
you like the most
teacher teacher and so the question I
have is what does it mean to you to be a
teacher
well to me I try to impart everything
that I know to them and that they know
that they have the power to bring about
anything they want to bring that takes a
lot of courage to do most things I also
talk about the type of people in the
circus I said you can't just sort of do
this step your honor type of not only
that but that partner of yours you
better catch her you have to raise the
standard of what they're going from what
they're responsible for and I think now
when everybody's going but they want the
job so they're gonna try to please other
people all the time and that's a such a
hard thing to balance because you do
want to do that Tara I had a teacher in
high school
chemistry teacher in high school mr. V
on and he would say we have a quiz today
and we'd all grumble and he'd say if you
don't pass this quiz you're gonna fail
chemistry and if you fail chemistry
you're gonna fail high school and if you
fail high school you won't get a job and
if you don't get a job you're gonna be
homeless on the street so if you don't
pass this quiz you're gonna be homeless
on the street so how do you raise the
stakes without scaring people raising
the stakes has to do with knowing that
you're responsible port once you get on
the stage they can't see the
choreographer they're looking at you so
the responsibility and how soon do you
need that information when you first
hear something you have to hear it as if
you were going to teach and the first
things that go into your brain are the
things you retain the most so you try to
get it right at the front end yeah so
you want to get the engagement very
early on so you're building mistakes you
got to put the person in the driver's
seat so they were already responsible
and then you raise the standard of the
actual performance of what they're doing
the importance of it the immediacy of it
all of that you want them to focus on
something that is that important that
requires that amount of focus when I see
people take over the process of their
own learning so when I feel like I can
step back and it's not like it's
necessarily this big explosion but you
can just feel them easing away from your
voice in a way and their own voice kind
of emerging it could be the way that
they move the way they take over
something that you've given them is it
like being a parent and watching your
child leave and become somewhat
independent I'm not letting my children
there's less anxiety but yes it's sort
of what how did you learn to be a
teacher I had great teachers who was one
of your great teachers her name is Betty
shoulder she's German she came to this
country I danced with Martha Graham very
briefly because she was very badly
injured but she became a choreography
teacher what did you learn from her she
was wise she taught composition so the
first thing she taught me was how to
look at dance I was never planning to be
choreographer and it's good thing
because if I had been Clanton would have
been tragic if that had been what I
wanted because they had no ability but
she taught us how to see like a good
painter you know you look at what's in
front of your face
they taught me how to learn and
understand movement I also have enough
technical skills I can put a dance
together there's some craft but to have
an eye for movement is a huge thing that
she taught me but she also taught me
something much more important than that
which is that she could be very very
blunt but it was never disempowering and
it was never personal it was just clear
so if you did a little study and she
would say it's simply not working not
you're not working it's simply not
working and then we would say try facing
upstage you tried this you always had
the ability to make choices and to make
changes I like that it's simply not
working versus you're not working and
again it goes to this idea that you said
before which is we want to tell people
they have capacity capability that
everybody has Worth and telling people
they have no Worth they have no value if
you say you got it you know you're wrong
or you got it wrong versus it's not
working I love how it disconnects the
human being from the result a final
question for you can you share a pointed
lesson that you have learned about life
well when my my mother died she was an
incredible person she was 103 and I was
asleep at home got a phone call from her
caregivers mummys going to jump in a cab
I actually say goodbye to my mother on
my cell phone in a cab can you believe
it when people could have sized cell
phones I said uh-uh but anyway she was
ready to go and my niece held the phone
to her ear and I said what am I going to
say to my mother
the last thing she'll hear and I just
said thank you for everything
I think gratitude is is one of my most
valued things that I have in my life I'm
really grateful to all the people and
for the life I have an enormous amount
of gratitude and I guess if you have
gratitude in a sense of appreciating
what you have for yourself and what you
have to give it's kind of hard to be
totally pessimist because it's it that's
a process it's a living process that
kind of been destructible everyday to
end with a gratitude to say what am i
grateful for forces us to find something
good about the day I think and I think
you know with this 24-hour news cycle
where the news is incentivized to show
us things that scare us because it is
good for their ratings which is good for
their advertising I think sometimes we
we stop seeing the good in the world and
start to believe the world is bad or
humanity is bad and if we if we have
this practice of ending every day to
find something that we were grateful for
I think it it's more than just a nice
idea it makes us all optimists I think
this is what turns someone into an
optimist which is you start to recognize
that there is something every day that
is good right and it could be something
small I have four little things that sit
on my desk and each one of them came
from an encounter that I have for the
person one of them was a stranger but
they're all symbols of what we've been
talking about and I have them like a
little altar one of them was a healing
stick that someone gave me one of them's
a little prayer book that a woman on the
bus gave to me because I helped her on
the bus and she said this may not seem
like a big thing to you but it just
saved my life
there are little objects that represents
such pivotal moments exchanges have you
ever heard of the chemical oxytocin No
so we're emotional beings but we're also
chemistry right and so there are four
primary chemicals in our body that are
responsible for a lot of our emotions
and a lot of our behavior endorphins
which you
about is it a dancer you push your body
really really hard you have an endorphin
rush or you tell a good joke we can tell
a good joke or you eat chocolate
dopamine which is responsible for the
feeling we get when we find something
we're looking for we accomplish
something like I did it or there it is
you know that little bit of elation you
get when you find your phone or your
keys serotonin which is its pride and
it's also accomplishment so you know
when our kids are saying look at me look
at me look at me look at me watch me
jump in the pool watch me jump in the
pool they want the audience and they
want us to say great job right that sort
of recognition and then you have
oxytocin and oxytocin is responsible for
all the warm and fuzzies all the
unicorns and rainbows okay it's the
thing that gives us feelings of love and
connection and friendship it's all of
that mushy mushy stuff and oxytocin
there are many many ways to get it human
contact is one of them this is why when
someone's having a hard time we put our
hand on their back and say it's okay we
don't just stand next to them and say
it's alright that's why a hug really
matters in times of good and bad but one
of the ways in which you get oxytocin is
by performing an act of generosity that
when you do something for someone else
with no expectation of anything in
return you feel good right oxytocin is
responsible for that feeling and when
somebody does something nice for us with
no expectation of anything in return
you get a shot of oxytocin it feels good
when somebody does something nice for us
and we feel sort of a nicer bond towards
them and three of those gifts that were
given to you were given to you because
you did something nice for someone and
they felt so warm toward you that they
wanted to give you a symbol of their
gratitude but perhaps one of my favorite
things about oxytocin is that witnessing
an act of generosity releases oxytocin
and the more oxytocin we have in our
bodies the more generous we actually
become it's biology its Mother Nature's
Way of trying to get us to look after
each other and so when we witness
somebody do something nice it actually
makes us be nicer and if we hear a story
of somebody giving it actually makes us
want to go do good so you telling the
story
helping someone on the bus which was a
small act for you insignificant you
probably would have forgotten about it
had you not been given this gift to
memorialize that event and simply you
and I talking about it releases oxytocin
and somebody who's listening and might
make them do something nice for somebody
that might be innocuous today or the
story you told of your final words to
your mother I mean you choked me up when
you said it because I immediately think
of the people that I could say thank you
to and you you are such a bright light I
just love how you show up in the world I
think there is more struggle than you
let on and I think there's more
difficulty but you are such a bright
light and you are so forward focused
about and you talked about where am I
going
not what am i necessarily going through
but where am I going and that for some
reason allows for you not to notice or
be as affected by the darkness and the
tunnel because you so focus on the light
at the end I I think that's too bad I
just I don't want you to think that I
was withholding bad experiences I think
what you just said it's sort of more the
case and by the way I don't think you
would held anything I really do think
that you're just so focused on light
you're it's been such a delight to talk
to thank you so so much for taking the
time I really appreciate it I'll talk to
you real soon bye I hope you enjoyed
this bit of optimism if you'd like more
please subscribe wherever you like to
listen to podcasts I hope you'll join me
next time until then take care of
yourself and take care of each other
[Music]